[Music]
well if I ever get over there I warned
you to put up your dukes
I'm ready for you oh well let's see what
we've got
whoa would be a shame if someone killed
them all
just jump well alright then I'll do
whatever you tell me to come along
Little Billy okay let's try this bottle
run is a bit more complicated than I had
previously anticipated yeah only lost a
foot don't need that for pow ladies you
lose like you want a taste of my fist
got your head I killed you dead I'm
gonna rhyme and then put you to bed lady
lady you so fine lady you so fine you
blow my mind just as let me boon walk to
impress you a bit ha ha
poke my head up you didn't see nothing
oh not even close to hurting boy what
you're gonna charm me with that poon
over there
oh no I'm so close alright cookies we're
going into a battle zone so you're gonna
need to be at your best but she'll be
with your would cater you haven't even
gotten into the battle zone and yet
you're already moist okay I'm not gonna
be beaten by a freaking bottle run okay
all right okay all right oh the bluth
staircar son there's always money in the
banana stand there's always money in the
banana stand there's always money
kill me pardon me sir so have you heard
of Jesus why am I going back one more
time for good luck sweet moves
oh sorry little Billy are you okay over
there you don't look so good
Billy Billy what's wrong ah you're not
gonna beat me you're not gonna beat me
you son of a [ __ ] you're not gonna oh
well they lost an arm I definitely don't
need that purple sward throw well hello
little kitty hello there how about you
just let me I'm sorry about to get here
have a candy bar it's delicious and good
for you goes right up your ass parently
sorry about that bar I kitties this time
don't fail or betray me don't die when
you run into the wall okay good
those jewels I know your body's a rather
fun to them oh yeah you want some you
want some bro you want some Oh No you
out of arrows over there okay we're
gonna beat this all right how do I keep
losing now I just gotta get out it's
gonna go out of the box okay we're doing
good so far oh I'm doing good so far
[Applause]
rope swing / no no you
if you poke my head 900k their neon ball
throw you got some arrows of grass
survived death war I don't think this is
a very safe death row wait wait hang on
let's not get it in the death I got it
in the death again no the glass bridge
wait man what happens if we loop all
right okay this seems okay nothing seems
bad so far I'm not even pressing oh all
right kid we're gonna avoid the big
balls you know how we're gonna fly you
know how to fly when you're the bicycle
man do you know do you know Oh losing
momentum
oh there we go bye kids this mother
[ __ ] Louisville I swear
- crap no no death okay keep it all
together keep it all together all right
okay
make it rain make it rain with the blood
of my enemies why I think I shall
[Laughter]
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what you
saw and you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel will help the
channel grow please leave a like add it
to your favorites or share with your
friends on Facebook and Twitter thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]